a teacher randomly chooses a two-person
team from a group of four students the
first person chosen will be the
presenter and the second person will be
the researcher two of the students Amir
and Erin are boys
the other two students Caitlin and Deniz
are girls all the possible outcomes of
the team selections are listed are all
of possible outcomes of the team
selection are listed below and actually
just put it to the right right over here
and you see all of the possible outcomes
here's here we see on the presenter
here's three outcomes where Amir as a
presenter and then in each of those
three you essentially have each of the
other three people being a potential
researcher Erin Caitlin or Deniz here
these outcomes four through six
Erin as a presenter and then you have
the other three people being the the
potential being the researcher and then
you see the all the situations for
kaitland Caitlin with Amir Caitlin with
Erin Caitlin with the knees and then you
have all the situations where Deniz is
the presenter Deniz presenter Amir
researcher Deniz presenter Erin
researcher Deniz presenter Caitlin
researcher fair enough then they tell us
if we take outcomes 2 3 5 6 7 8 10 which
they marked in red right over here 2 3 5
6 7 8 10 and 11 as a subset of the
sample space which of the options
describe this subset alright let's redo
these and think about which of these
describes the subsidence you to pause
the video and think about this on your
own before I work through them so this
first option and we could we might be
able to select more than one of these
the subset is comprised of all the
outcomes where the team is made up of
one boy and one girl
so let's see this is the these are both
of these are the outcomes where you have
a mere paired up with a girl there's two
possible girls that Amir could be paired
up with Amir as a presenter and one of
the girls is researchers so there's two
outcomes here here's Erin as a presenter
and then and there's two scenarios where
he's paired up with a girl either
Kaitlyn or Deniz so these first four
outcomes two three five and six these
are the situations where we have a boy
presenter paired all the different
scenarios
we have a boy presenter paired with a
girl researcher that's these four
outcomes and now let's look at outcomes
seven and eight this is where you have
Kaitlyn as a presenter paired with a boy
researcher and this is Deniz as a
presenter outcomes 1011 with a boy
researcher so outcomes 7 8 10 11 are all
the situations where you have a girl
presenter and a boy researcher so taken
together this is a subset of all the
outcomes where the team is made up of
one boy and one girl
and you could see that all of the other
all of the other scenarios involve
either two boys or two girls here's two
boys these are two boys here's two boys
here are two girls and here are two
girls right over here
let's look at the other options the
subset is comprised of all the outcomes
where the team is made up of either all
boys are all girls no every scenario is
one boy or one girl one boy or one boy
and one girl so we can rule this one out
the subset is comprised of all the
outcomes where the team is not made up
of all boys and not made up of all girls
so not all boys and not all girls and I
think that's right because if you were
to say let's let's take the the subset
where we're not all boys well then you
would rule out this one this one and
well those two and if you were to rule
out not all girls you would rule out
that one and that one and the subset is
made up of all of the things left over
so the subset is comprised of all the
outcomes where the team has not made up
of all boys and not made up of all and
not made up of all girls so all of these
so it lets me check that one off as well
the subset is comprised of all the
outcomes where the team has a girl as a
presenter and a boys a researcher well
we see that's true four seven eight ten
and eleven but that is not true that is
not true four outcomes two three five
and six and those outcomes you have a
boy as the presenter and a girl as a
researcher so this what they've
described here where the team has a girl
as a presenter and a boy as a researcher
this is a
set of the subsets we're talking about
but the subset is not comprised only of
this it's comprised of this and
scenarios where a boy is a presenter and
a girl is a researcher so I would click
these first two